uh can you give a brief history of the
SpaceX rocket engines that were uh used
that we haven't covered so you mentioned
all started with the Merlin engine and a
custom engine what um yeah through that
lens yeah what's there the engines are
relatively small number which is which
is easy for us there's the other Merlin
and Merlin's evolved throughout time to
be from like the Merlin to the Merlin
one seed and Merlin 1D to the Merlin 1D
full thrust and all these other kind of
tweaks of the same architecture uh
Kestrel ended with Falcon one
um they also have the Merlin vacuum
engine which is the upper stage engine
for Falcon 9. same relative uh system
but just optimized for vacuum so it has
a much larger Bell nozzle there's the
Draco thrusters which you know you kind
of can consider engines well they are
rocket engines but they're just small
they're not like the orbital engines
there's these super Draco engines which
are the abort thrusters on on crew
Dragon capsule and then nowadays they
have the Raptor engine and the Raptor
vacuum variant but they've already had
two versions of raptor we've already
seen kind of the Raptor development
engine
um we kind of seemed like a raptor 1.5
whereas kind of taking hints of the
future Raptor but now we're well within
the well within what you know you'd
consider a Raptor 2 variant
and that's really it yeah for the uh the
Raptor maybe I'll ask you that
separately but I like in general and
people
who doesn't know whoever the astronaut
is but if you don't somehow know go go
go check his your YouTube channel out
you're an incredible educator about the
super technical and uh the more sort of
even the the philosophical the actual
like the the actual space travel so you
go down to the raw details of it and
there's just great videos on the Raptor
engine
um
I think you have one on Merlin uh and
and also actual tours with Elon where he
discusses some of those things on one of
the tourists he says uh he's full of
good lines that guy uh he says something
about uh the number of fiddly bits
and he's uh the number of fiddly bits
was decreased between Raptor two and
Raptor one yeah and I I think that's
actually a really beautiful
representation of um the engineering
efforts there which is constantly trying
to simplify increase the efficiency of
the engines but also
uh simplify the design so you can
manufacture it and in general
simplification leads to better
performance and testing you know and
everything so the number of fiddly bits
I'm sure there's a Wikipedia page on
that now as an index is actually a
really good one well and when you think
about it I I don't know of any other
company prior that had kind of try to
measure their performance of their
engine not and like thrust to weight
ratio or like how efficient it is like
in specific impulse but literally in
like dollar to thrust ratio like how
much does this engine cost yeah how much
thrust can it produce and like using
that as a trade study instead of just
like pure metrics of you know because at
the end of the day like okay if it's if
it's cheaper and does you know x amount
of work even if it's less efficient it
can actually be better long term
and so I guess another way it's not even
just thrust I don't know if that metric
is used but basically the cost of
getting one kilogram
of thing up into space yeah that's
basically what they're trying to
minimize especially yeah at the end of
the day that is definitely the ultimate
metric is how much does one kilogram
cost to orbit eventually you know and
but there's it's so funny because space
flight is just the ultimate you know
it's the ultimate compromise every
little thing any variable can just
change everything else so you can tweak
so many different things to get to
different numbers and conclusions you
know but even things like on your first
stage when you're when you're the
Rocket's pointing straight up and the
engines are pointing straight down
you're dealing more with the thrust to
weight ratio of the rocket so how much
thrust is it producing versus how much
is gravity pulling down on it is
actually a more important metric than
how raw efficient the engine is so it's
funny that in space it's kind of the
opposite thrust to weight ratio doesn't
really matter
uh what really matters is the actual the
specific impulses color like the the
nozzle escape velocity of the or the
injection velocity of the how fast is
the gas moving is like the more
important number on orbit but it's it's
just so crazy because there's all these
like I would just love to see
the trade studies you know when you're
like trying to figure out like is this
more important than this or this or this
and it's like you change this one little
thing and all of a sudden you know like
all the everything changes it's just
even the profile like the launch profile
the trajectory of it the I mean
everything
everything I wonder what that trade-off
discussions are like because you can't
really perfectly plan everything so and
you always have to have some
spare leeway on on you know especially
as you're testing new vehicles like
Starship yeah so margins are important
yeah having having a margin giving all
the uncertainty that's there that's
really interesting like how they do
those kinds of trade-offs because
they're also rapidly designing and
redesigning and re-engineering
and uh the ultimately you want to give
yourself the freedom to constantly
innovate but then through the process of
testing
you solidify the thing that can be
relied upon especially if it's a crude
Mission yeah that how to do that in a
rapid cycle I I remember at some point
that NASA as they're leading up to
Flying humans for the first time for
NASA
um you know there's some talk that like
we're gonna do a design freeze because
SpaceX does evolve and iterate so
quickly you know they were saying that
it was leading because especially at the
time it was a mission called Amo 6 and
they lost a rocket they've only lost two
rockets like ever really as far as um
you know trying to get something to
space for the Falcon 9 sorry
um and the second one Amos 6 I mean that
was back in 2016 so it's it's been a
long time
and uh but at the time you know they're
looking at flying humans in the near
future
and it's like if you guys keep tweaking
this thing every time you take it out to
the pad really's gonna be a problem you
know and so there is some pressure
from NASA to kind of slow down on that
iterative process and uh but that is
also why they were able to evolve the
Falcon 9 to be what it is today is
because they did just evolve it so
quickly literally like one after another
was never really the same and we're
definitely seeing that with Starship now
like it's
evolved so quickly that you just can't
even keep up with it you know